miles Garrett joining us on the program
have you heard from the Cleveland Browns
Myles I have not yet do you expect to
hear from the Cleveland Browns how do
you look an orange in Brown I tried to
avoid weird in college but I don't think
I look too shabby in it oh okay so burnt
orange with Texas that's different than
Cleveland Browns orange though miles
yeah I think your phone's going in and
out there hold on hold on a second there
miles let's see if Richie can secure a
little better phone line there he went
deep I know yeah right away no no right
away yeah I don't know if they have a
combine for voices there cuz usually
guys who are 21 22 he's 21 years old
deep yeah maybe he's running a 40-yard
dash while he's doing this interview so
it kind of faded in and out there yeah I
forgot about the Texas burnt orange
there probably didn't like that color
what is it
a.m. color how would you yeah what's it
officially called is it what is it
officially called there I don't know but
I like when teams call Seahawk blue like
they make up a color so I would say
Aggie red maybe Aggie red now it's more
of a purple
maroon he's called Aggie maroon Aggie
maroon is that what it is okay it's uh
miles back with us
yes hey mom okay all right all right so
we've established that you're okay with
Cleveland Brown orange just not burnt
orange with Texas right yeah all right
the the best athlete in your family is
who that's hard that's our question I
can't really say myself cuz nice to have
a lot to do in my career and everybody
else has their own achievements in their
own respective sports so we'll just put
out a draw okay you ever your brother he
played in the NBA they did okay
your sister quite an athlete
national champion so when you sit around
do they do they brag about what their
accomplishment you know leggo hey miles
a nice nice little combine you had their
nice little career you got so far but
you know look at what we've done
yeah bring it up these me right back
down show me I got a long way to go
what did you think of your performance
at the combine I had a personal tired of
personal bests with my mouth vertical
and some other things like the broad it
did pretty well but uh so like I ran
slow and forced its quality I haven't
run of course it's four years I was like
a little tight
whoo how nervous are you when of all the
drills you did what's the one where you
started to do it you go oh boy oh boy
good or bad well you tell me either 140
as soon as I get out like my hip was
kind of sore and so I knew that gonna be
kind of rough that dish what is your uh
your best time at 274 for seven loop it
under that I've been for 43 you ran a
for 43 yes sir oh my goodness were you
any good at basketball
I was pretty good if there was a slam
dunk contest at the combo how do you
think you would have fared Oh episode I
give number one what were the questions
you got into combine that we're
interesting I don't know hearing other
guys questions is really funny to me I
didn't get any really strange questions
no what's your biggest regret
what drives you hurt some other guys you
like what did the snow scraper do wait
wait what's a cart
snow scraper do ya did anybody not know
that he told me it's grace no no well
you're gonna need to know that in
Cleveland no miles
I'll walk you're gonna get a bike no
you're not gonna be riding a bike in the
winter you can actually pay somebody to
clean your your your car windshield
there when you get to Cleveland what
other questions did you hear pretty good
though what's ask I would say you know
car scraper do I mean I feel like I
should have got that question see
there's on my piece don't wear the coat
oh yeah yeah it looks like you'll
probably be in the cold are you ok
playing in the cold yeah just follow me
I played in high school
we've had a couple games and then if I
seen it I was like 20 degrees 20 I think
it was 16 and I do put some layers on
and get out there start playing well we
met miles there's a difference between
Texas cold and Cleveland cold I mean
it's all this cold only only differences
they have heaters on the side either we
did yeah what did you study at am
architecture what do you want to do I
want to build houses for people less
fortunate than me oh cool you could also
with that voice you could probably go
into the media you could be in like a DJ
if you wanted to be there when I went to
Haiti I used to I played music on the
bus when we go to a roo we were going
for that day and they call me DJ
sunshine well let me hear a little what
do you got for me all right after you
yeah I didn't have like a radio - it was
a I played the music and I smiled a lot
so what were you doing in Haiti
ah there's a mission trip and how many
people went
I'll loop it over 30 and what now what
did you see down there what did you take
away that stays with you to this day so
many no people had such bad living
conditions and they were just so
positive about the you know where
they're at with Christ and how they
probably were in their life right now
no matter what state they were in they
were no happy loving caring and just
glad to see isn't know anything you know
we wanted to do to help there they
opened up and accepted us and we did the
same thing how important is your faith
to you I mean that's number one that
that's got me to this point and it was
you know take me further if I just keep
on don't keep on uh giving awkward you
know have you talked to Vaughn Miller
have not I mean I probably could find a
way to you know get in touch with them
but I got a lot of other things that
sound I'll play back down so what I find
sometimes I'll try to know Carlos and
pick his brain if you raised von Miller
right now in the forty what happens
think if I'm a pie from some suggestion
ready I think I can you know have a good
start you yeah there's no ties in the 40
miles know if there is a tie then we run
it again until we have a winner that's
the way it works you run it again you
know what Vaughn ran for for nine at the
combine and he didn't having a problem
with his hips are you going to the draft
no oh how come well bring your family to
the draft
I can't bring all my family to the dress
well how many well I got my parents
got my my siblings I got my uncle's
godmother Godfather I got some friends
that have I've known for over 15 years I
got some teammates coaches okay well
you're gonna be the number one pick in
the draft right so don't you want
everybody there to celebrate with you
there will and you and you save a whole
lot of money where you don't have to fly
all these people in okay great there's
your first really smart business
decision Myles I get that has it fed up
with what a good decision yep yep and
sounds like you got a few more in store
hey congrats so far and good luck on
draft night hopefully you get your wish
of where you want to go
oh that's number one so whoever it is
I'm for that
so you're going number one no matter
what somebody's taking you number one
somebody figment of war all right good
luck miles hi it's miles Garrett deep
voice got it in perspective they're
ready to go short with an answer when he
needs to be sometimes he'll expound upon
that a little bit but ready to go the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience